[Musique]
hélas leur boulot policière aux
relations communautaires pour la ville
de trois rivières
[Musique]
j'y vois un peu cassé dans un restaurant
et un policier serbe au café aux gens et
c'est un prélude le pour échanger à la
discussion
aujourd'hui on est là pour les activités
qui a fait les quatre policiers et une
heure et demie à deux heures une fois
par moore t pot énorme c'est pour dix
policiers non plus qu'ils viennent l'été
prochain des pauvres encore des
policiers qui mangeait des bains de
rencontre oui des fois le policier va
voir du café mais c'est plus les champs
les policiers sont souvent perçus comme
les méchaal est pas bon plein de
commentaires comme ça à chaque fois que
c'est une façon de démontrer que
réussissent c'est un humain qui est papa
qui est maman
je pense que c'est important aussi de
s'arrêter puis d'écouter la population
ce qu'ils ont à nous dire ce qu'on
faisait pas sous verre à vin non plus
on en a déjà référées des gens qui ont
beaucoup d'envié dans le coin de chez
nous peut-être des vendeuses de
stupéfiants donc on les réfère à ce
moment à lausanne caire
une femme davier des cop créer une
barrière aussi et puis quand on rentre
un café il faut expliquer le pourquoi
qu'on est ici
[Musique]
ça va être très cliché ce que je vais
dire mais j'ai toujours voulu faire ce
métier d'autres je pense de deuxième
année et c'est vraiment dans le but
d'aider les gens c'était ma priorité les
côté féminin est peut-être venu apporter
une façon d'intervenir que les sommes
n'avaient peut-être pas c'était
peut-être dans le temps plus directif
plus rude alors que la femme va
peut-être emporté le côté plus on vaut
parlementer on va essayer de trouver une
façon de régler sans sortir le gros à
tirana
j'aimerais qu'ils perçoivent la police
comme les personnes qui vont les aider
puis à la mi mai peut-être des ennemis
mais ça serait peut-être utopique de
penser c'est ce que j'aimerais par
contre c'est qu'avant de porter un
jugement qui prennent le temps
d'analyser la situation que ce soit dans
les médias ou aux pour le plein sur vos
réseaux sociaux
[Musique]
j'espère que c'est dur pour rester parce
que on investit beaucoup
tous les policiers communautaires pour
faire reconnaître que ça les besoins des
classes c'est un besoin pour la
communauté c'est un besoin également
pour les les corps de police aussi
le climat se faire servir par des pôles
6/4 même assez rare
[Musique]
on